I think the reason you've heard mixed  messages is that there are lots of  different brushes out there some are bad  some are fine and it depends a lot on  how you use them as well rough brushes  are not great you might be able to get  away with it if you're very gentle but  if you scrub your face too much or too  hard then Your Skin Barrier is coming  right off your skin should not feel raw  after cleansing they're also harder to  clean so a lot of people are probably  running the risk of rubbing bacteria and  mold into their raw skin silicone  brushes are a lot gentler and easier to  clean but again it can be tempting to  scrub too hard if you move it slowly  over your skin with gentle pressure and  if you make sure you keep it clean then  it's a good option I don't have the  discipline for this and I keep  forgetting to charge it so this is not  for me after a week it just sits in my  shower as a sad reminder of my failings  as a person but luckily fingers work  fine too